IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE ICN AND
HORNQVIST COME TOGETHER.
LAWRENCE WILD UP BY AHO.
ENDS THE ZONE., HE KNOWS WHERE
SLAVIN IS.
I THINK HEHE AHEAD IT IS LOMBER.
LOMBERD HORNQVIST BOTH GET G IN
STUDIO AS OUR RULES OFFIFI RELO.
CREASE OR IN THE
TERAVAINEN WITH A WHIRLING SHOT.
IT HAD NO BUSINESS GOING INTO  .
FIRST PERIOD FEATURED FOUR POWER
PLAYS, TWO FOR EACH TEAM.
HERE IS HORNRN
MARCHMENT WITH A TIP PLAY.
NOW IT IS
CAROLINA.
AND OBVIOUSLY A BETTER ONE BY
THE DEFENSEMAN, NUMBER 32 WITH
THOV.
Y ANDERSEN USING
EVERY PART OF THE LENG
BACK, AND HE SCORES!
ALEKSASA COMING.
HE GIVES HIM THE.
NEVER GOT QUITE WHERE HE WANTED
TO TO HIS RIGHT, STOPSCEBOOK DE.
WRIST SHOT.
YES.ES.
RIGHT OFF HIS RIGHT SKATE UNDER
THE BAR AND INrendan: MARCHMENTT
ANDERSON HAS WON A LOT OF GAMES,
BECAUSE HE HAS BEEN BETTER THAN
THE MAN ATOFF THE BAR.
AND HE GOT IT BACK ON D HE STEP
POINT.
>> Brendan: ON EXCHANGE FROM
YOU, PANGER, FOUR DAYS.
>> Darren: WE WILL GET THERE.
WATCH THE LEFT P
HERE'S BENNETT WITH SOME OPEN
ICE.
CARRYING IN FOR FLORIDA.
BENNETT WITH THE A SHOT.D
PRESSURE IN THE O ZONE AT
FIVE-O-O
MARCHMENT MAKES SURE IT IS DEEP.
WRAPPED RNDS THE BOARDS.
.
THEY SCORE!
YOU CAN SEE THAT PUCK TO THE
RIGHT OF ANDERSEN.
IT HITS A BODY
AND THE PANTHERS AND HURRICANES
PLAY A